5 % je vous propose je vous rappelle que
dans quelques instants nous devrions
entendre une communication
gouvernementale du chef du gouvernement
en direct de l'hôtel de Matignon harl
chabo c'est la deuxième fois en quelques
semaines qu'alin Jupé s'adresse ainsi
directement à l'opinion oui
effectivement dans les sujets grave et
important comme il considère ce soir
effectivement Alain Jupé préfère
s'adresser directement à l'opinion et au
français il veut convaincre sûrement les
Français ce soir comme il a tenté de
convaincre la représentation nationale
comme l'ont dit à propos des députés de
la nécessité de la réforme il compte
sûrement lui aussi à nouveau expliquer
au français les détails de la réforme et
préciser les garanties qu'il a donné cet
après-midi aux fonctionnaires notamment
pour essayer de débloquer le conflit et
la crise je rappelle que Nicole nota
toujours avec nous et qu'elle aura
l'occasion de répondre ensuite aux
propositions du Premier ministre que
nous allons entendre dans quelques
instants en direct de l'hôtel de
Matignon chers compatriotes j'ai
souhaité ce soir vous parler
personnellement parce que je sais que la
vie quotidienne de beaucoup d'entre vous
est difficile et que depuis quelques
temps elle est plus difficile encore je
pense à ceux d'entre vous qui veulent
travailler et qui doivent parfois se
lever à 3 ou 4h du matin pour rejoindre
leur bureau ou leur atelier dans les
grandes villes vous devez parfois faire
des heures de marche et avec le froid
qui revient c'est de plus en plus
dur puis je pense aussi au grévistes je
sais que ça n'est pas une décision
facile que de décider la grève pour les
plus modestes cela implique des
sacrifices alors il n'est plus possible
de continuer comme cela nous sommes dans
une situation de blocage et
d'affrontement dont chacune et chacun va
finir par pâtir il faut en sortir il
faut en sortir d'urgence et pour ma part
je souhaite de tout cœur
que les choses
s'apaisent certains formulent des
exigences ils disent le préalable à
toute discussion c'est que le
gouvernement retire son plan de réforme
et de sauvegarde de la sécurité sociale
et bien je veux vous parler les yeux
dans les
yeux je ne retirerai pas le plan de
réforme et de sauvegarde de la sécurité
sociale parce que ce serait une erreur
et je dirais même une faute que de le
faire cela irait contre l'intérêt de
chacune et de chacun d'entre vous et
contre l'intérêt de la France ces
réformes nous les avons longuement
préparé et je crois aujourd'hui qu'elles
sont à la fois urgentes et justes nous
allons les faire dans la concertation et
elles donneront des résultats elles
seront utiles voilà au moins quatre
raisons pour lesquelles il ne faut pas
les retirer et je voudrais essayer si
vous voulez bien m'écouter ce soir de
vous en convaincre
elles sont d'abord urgentes si nous les
retirions que se passerait-il il n'y a
aucune autre proposition qui soit faite
par qui que ce soit ce serait donc le
statut quo l'immobilisme et ce serait
très dangereux je voudrais en prendre
quelques exemples d'abord l'Assurance
Maladie vous savez bien que chaque année
on dépense en prestation plus qu'on
encaisse en
cotisation cela veut dire que il y a un
moment où l'assurance maladive va être
en cessation de paiement on ne pourra
plus vous rembourser et ça je ne le veux
pas bien entendu autre exemple mes
régimes spéciaux de retraite dont on
parle beaucoup ces temps-ci c'est-à-dire
les retraites des fonctionnaires des
agents de la RATP ou de la SNCF là
encore il y a un problème pas tout de
suite pas demain pas après-demain mais
dans 10 ou 15 ans et gouverner c'est
prévoir ce qui va se passer dans 10 ou
15 ans quel est le problème vous le
comprenez facilement
euh comment ça marche ce sont les
travailleurs actifs qui payent des
cotisations afin de financer les
retraites de ceux qui sont
déjà pensionnés or que se passe-t-il on
rentre dans la vie de travail de plus en
plus tard on arrête de travailler de
plus en plus tôt il y a donc de moins en
moins de cotisants et puis dans le même
temps les retraités qui ont pris leur
retraite de plus en plus jeune vivent et
c'est heureux grâce rendu au ciel vivent
de plus en plus longtemps le rapport
entre les cotisants et les inactifs est
donc déséquilibré et ça va continuer
voilà pourquoi il faut faire quelque
chose autre exemple encore la SNCF nous
sommes tous très fiers de cette grande
entreprise nationale nous connaissons
les TGV c'est une des belles
réalisations de l'industrie française
mais ce qu'on ne nous a pas dit ce qu'on
nous a caché trop longtemps c'est que
cette entreprise ne se porte pas bien
elle a des dettes considérables je ne
vous donnerai pas les chiffres parce que
il ne parle pas imagination elle perd de
l'argent chaque année et ce qui est plus
grave peut-être c'est que elle
transporte proportionnellement de moins
en moins de passagers et de marchandises
parce que elle résiste mal à la
concurrence d'autres modes de transport
en particulier la route et donc la
encore si nous ne faisons rien cette
entreprise va aller vers des difficultés
extrêmement graves il y a donc urgence à
agir et je voudrais que vous en soyez
convaincu ces réformes urgentes elles
sont aussi justes nous avons tout fait
pour qu'elles le soit ne croyez pas tous
les mensonges on vous raconte depuis 15
jours en vous expliquant que les efforts
ne seront pas équitablement répartis ce
n'est pas vrai la première chose que
nous voulons faire pour l'assurance
maladie c'est d'abord un régime
universel ça veut dire quoi actuellement
les Français ne sont pas égaux devant
l'assurance maladie ils ne reçoivent pas
tous les mêmes prestations et bien nous
voulons que ça change nous voulons la
même couverture maladie pour tous les
Français c'est une mesure de justice et
puis nous voulons aussi
que les efforts soient équitablement
répartis je vous l'ai dit et là je
voudrais rétablir une fois encore
quelques vérité il n'est pas vrai que
les plus petits vont supporter le poids
du redressement de l'Assurance Maladie
deux exemples précis le remboursement de
la dette sociale rien ne sera demander
aux 5 de millions de Français les plus
modestes et pour la cotisation maladie
supplémentaire là aussi je l'ai expliqué
déjà à la télévision je dois le redire
parce que ceci a été un peu perdu de vue
les retraités qui ne sont pas imposant
il y en a plus de 6 millions c'est près
de 60 % de tous les retraités ne
supporteront pas cette cotisation
supplémentaire
et les chômeurs qui ont des ressources
inférieures au SMIC 2 millions et demi
d'entre eux plus de 80 % de tous les
chômeurs ne la supporteront pas non plus
vous le voyez les Français les plus
modestes ne seront pas appelés à
participer au redressement financier de
la sécurité sociale justice aussi en ce
qui concerne la SNCF on vous a beaucoup
parlé du contrat de plan bien je
voudrais vous dire ce que c'est que ce
contrat de plan il ne consiste n aucune
manière à remettre en cause le caractère
d'entreprise publique de la SNCF elle
restera un service public j'en prends
l'engagement il ne remet pas en question
non plus le statut des cheminaux qui
doit être défendu et il prévoit un très
large effort de la collectivité pour
redresser la situation de la SNCF les
contribuables nous toutes et nous tous
nous allons apporter dès 1996 et sans
contrepartie 37 milliards d'aide
financière à la SNCF pour lui permettre
de payer ses dettes et ça continuera
ensuite il n'y a pas de blocage des
salaires à la SNCF il n'y a pas non plus
de liste de suppression de ligne ceci
n'est pas vrai ça ne figure pas dans le
contrat de plan qu'est-ce que nous
demandons nous demandons que
l'entreprise se modernise qu'elle motive
davantage tous ses collaborateurs et
qu'elle fasse preuve d'un nouveau
dynamisme commercial c'est bien le moins
qu'on puisse demander à une grande
entreprise publique voilà donc pourquoi
les réformes sont justes nous allons
aussi les faire dans la concertation ces
réformes on vous dit parfois que le
gouvernement va tout décider tout seul
ce n'est pas vrai prenons l'exemple des
ordonnances ça n'est pas la première
fois qu'on fait des ordonnances tous les
gouvernements anon fait qu'il soit de
droite ou de gauche je me suis engagé à
ce que ces ordonnances qui sont
nécessaires pour aller vite soitent
objet d'une information auprès du
Parlement mais aussi auprès des
partenaires sociaux je l'ai annoncé cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale de
même j'ai demandé demandé à Monsieur
Barraud vous le connaissez vous l'avez
vu souvent ces jours derniers vous avez
apprécié à la fois son calme et son
ouverture d'esprit j'ai demandé que
Monsieur barreau reçoive toutes les
confédérations syndicales pour organiser
cette concertation j'ai prévu une table
ronde sur l'avenir de no service public
auquel nous sommes très attachés et puis
enfin il y a les régimes spéciaux de
retraite et là je veux être aussi très
clair aucune décision n'est prise à
priori je vous ai dit pourquoi ces
régimes connaissaient des difficulté et
bien il faut remettre tout ça à plat et
j'ai chargé une commission composée de
personnalités très respecté très très
éminente de toute sensibilité de faire
un livre blanc un peu comme Monsieur
Rocard l'avait fait pour le régime
général il y a quelques années mais sur
la base de ce livre blanc le moment venu
nous prendrons les décisions en
concertation avec tous ceux que cela
concerne enfin et c'est la 4e raison
pour laquelle il faut faire ces réformes
je suis persuadé qu'elles seront utiles
qu'elles réussiront elles ne sont pas
faites pour brimer pour gêner elles sont
faites pour aider pour aider la SNCF
pour aider l'Assurance Maladie pour
aider les régimes de retraite à se
redresser et je suis persuadé que la
France a en elle-même tous les atouts
pour réussir je ne comprends pas cette
espèce de sinistrose ou de morosité qui
est en train de s'installer est-ce que
nous mesurons suffisamment bien la
chance que nous avons d'être français et
je vous pose tout simplement la question
y a-t-il un seul pays au monde où vous
préféreriez vivre plutôt qu'en
France je le dis cela tout
particulièrement à nos jeunes ils se
sont beaucoup exprimés depuis quelques
temps parfois dans la rue parfois
brouillamment c'est de leur râge et il
faut essayer de les comprendre il y a
les attentes des lycéens et des
étudiants il y a aussi parfois
l'angoisse des jeunes des quartiers en
difficulté nous les avons entendu nous
les avons compris et le ministre de
l'éducation nationale François Baayou a
annoncé dimanche dernier des mesures
d'urgence qui rejoignent complètement ce
qui avaient été envisagé donc
aujourd'hui sur ce plan-là toutes les
raisons sont réunies toutes les
conditions sont réunies pour que
l'université les universités françaises
se remettent au travail j'ai bien
conscience que derrière ces mesures
d'urgence il y a quelque chose de plus
grave et de plus profond
et ce phénomène plus grave et plus
profond c'est quoi c'est tout simplement
l'angoisse de l'avenir c'est cette
question que nous lanc les jeunes à quoi
va servir le diplôme qui me sera donné
par bonne université est-ce qu'il
débouchera sur un emploi sur un travail
et là nous retrouvons ce qui est le
fléau essentiel aujourd'hui auquel nous
devons faire face et contre lequel nous
devons lutter qui est le fléau du
chômage j'avais fait de la bataille pour
l'emploi la priorité des priorités de
mon gouvernement et je n'ai pas changé
d'avis depuis 6 mois nous avons marqué
quelques points le chômage de longue
durée a reculé et le contrat initiative
emploi qui avait été un des grands
engagements de Jacques Chirac pendant sa
campagne présidentielle est une réussite
il concerne près de 150000 français
aujourd'hui en revanche et je le dis en
toute franchise pour le chômage des
jeunes nous avons subi des revers il a
progressé depuis de ou 3 mois et ce
n'est pas acceptable il faut donc que
toute la nation se mobilise il faut
faire des réformes au lycée à
l'université les réformes de fond elles
aussi trop longtemps différées qui vont
nous permettre d'attaquer ce fléo et
puis il faut aussi que tous les
employeurs se mobilisent et je m'adresse
là à toutes les entreprises aux petites
aux moyennes aux grandes nous avons fait
beaucoup d'efforts envers elle depuis
quelques mois nous avons allégé leur
charg et pris toute une série de
décisions ion qui correspondent à ce
qu'elles attendaient pour trouver un
nouveau dynamisme et bien il faut que à
leur tour maintenant ell tendent la main
aux jeunes qu'elle leur offre une chance
d'entrer pour une fois dans la vie de
travail qu'elle leur mette un peu le
pied à l'étrier c'est ce que j'ai appelé
le devoir national d'insertion il faut
maintenant le concrétiser ce sera la
nouvelle frontière que nous allons
ouvrir dans les mois qui viennent la
mobilisation pour l'insertion des jeunes
qu'ils soi étudiants ou pas étudiants
des quartiers difficulté ou ou ou des
autres quartiers leur insertion dans la
vie professionnelle voilà mes chers
compatriotes ce que je voulais vous dire
ce soir la France a besoin de réformes
nous allons les faire nous allons les
faire dans la concertation nous allons
les faire pour réussir et nous
réussirons si nous retrouvons entre nous
Français et français ce lien cette
fraternité qui font notre force il ne
faut pas dresser les Français les uns
contre les autres les usagers contre les
grévistes les cheminaux contre les
salariés du secteur privé tout ceci ce
sont de vieux combats ou de vieux débats
il faut se réunir se rassembler se
mobiliser pour réussir nous allons
réussir je le crois de tout mon cœur et
de toutes mes
forces